melissa is in Kansas hi Melissa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
hi Ken how are you good
great how can we help thank you for
taking my call um okay so I hope I'm
kind of conflicted right now I currently
work for a large nationwide bank I have
for eight years and I just found you
guys about two months ago and have been
starting on my baby steps I'm currently
working baby step two and it kind of
changed the way that I look at like
credit and savings and things like that
and of course that those are both huge
parts and what I do at work is trying to
teach people about both of these things
but credit is also still a huge thing at
work that of course I am trying to help
people within that I am required to help
people with but part of it is of course
taking applications and things like that
and of course now the way that I look at
credit is different so I'm having a
problem juggling what maybe I currently
believe as credit is versus like why I'm
required to do a work for credit so do
you want to leave if you could leave
today if you had something to step into
would you know I love everything about
you like you like the function you like
the function of the work describe what
you love most about the job just think
of it forget the moment that in the day
when you're where you're helping people
obtain credit which feels wrong to you
outside of that what do you love most
about the day what are you doing think
of the task the function the role you're
playing that you really love what is it
well for one I really actually love the
people that I work with they make it
really enjoyable and I really like the
part about being able to educate people
um I think that that's really important
and it just amazes me how many people
out there are just entirely clueless
about anything really when it comes to
credit savings even balancing a checking
account it's absolutely amazing so I
we enjoy like the teaching part of it
it's just hard for me to try to teach
people oh don't do credit or don't apply
for this loan and said let's work on
building a savings when you know the
bank is kind of part of working at a
bank it's trying to get credit so if you
weren't required to tell people about
credit products and credit opportunities
you'd feel pretty awesome yeah yeah I
think you gotta look for that now Dave
I'm curious but cuz I I sit there and I
look at that and I understand what she's
saying she's saying she has a values
problem there's some value Collision
going on
and she can't keep feeling bad about
credit I think what will happen over the
over the long haul melissa is you will
eventually start to feel a big
disconnection to the work despite all
the positives you just said this credit
thing will continue to eat at you so I'm
telling you you don't have to jump now
don't rush but I'd be looking for what
you just described the environment that
you have the culture is good and then
the work that you're doing that you
really love
where can you do that and not have that
values wrestling match every day yeah
exactly and you know in two there's
there are different kinds of cultures
within banks for instance your regional
banks and credit unions aren't nearly as
aggressive in the peddling of debt as
some of the big household name huge like
the Bank of America type things and some
of those places I if you don't hit your
quota on issuing credit cards car loans
whatever it is eventually you're going
to get booted for not hitting your quota
and so you know III love the the level
of character that you're showing in that
you are very positive about your
employment you're saying good things
about your employer don't stay so long
that that stops okay and it I don't
think you need to leave today this is a
new leaf
owned values collision six months ago
didn't exist and so take your time but
also don't let II don't let the the
values collision as Ken called it erode
you're saying good things about your
co-workers and even your employer when
you cease to be able to be loyal and do
what they've hired you to do and be kind
to the people that work there and kind
about the people that run the business
then that's when it's time to go before
you start talking negatively and go well
you know I cuz but Ken sings true
eventually those things will start to
deteriorate if you don't find some level
of reconciliation in your mind on this
values collision and and I wouldn't tell
you you absolutely have to quit I matter
fact I don't think you should today but
I do think you just need to be aware
that this is going to take you one
direction or another and you need to
keep these this incredibly wonderful
character you have where you speak
highly of your employer until you leave
and then even then you know don't stay
if there are horrible people just don't
stay but that's not the case you're
dealing with good people you're saying
and people you like working with and so
you don't want to do that it's a it's a
good it's a very very good question hey
thanks for the call
and can I get the question a lot over
the years of you know I went through
Financial Peace University on a
restaurant now I feel weird taking
credit cards right well I don't I don't
tell you know are on the car dealership
I feel weird for than seing a car yeah I
think the thing you'd have to do at that
point is I'm in the business and have
been for thirty years telling people cut
up your credit cards don't borrow money
under any circumstances so for me to
borrow money or offer debt here in any
way would be so hypocritical it would be
unbelievable it's different if you
taught Financial Peace University at
your church and you own a Pizza Hut you
know that that's you're not you're
engaged in the pizza business great
point and so if you take credit cards
there I'm not mad at you you take debit
cards credit cards now what you wouldn't
want to do because you don't believe
in the misuse and the overuse of debt
you wouldn't want to be involved in
pushing it on someone or if you're a car
dealer ripping them off with a subprime
loan you wouldn't be involved in that so
you can you know you can dial back
without turning off in some of these
industries where you're not there and an
example in her case would be hey working
for a credit union where they're all
about teaching and all about building up
savings and they have some debt products
but you're not like the black sheep of
the family unless you sell 42 credit
cards today yeah she could also work for
for example one of our smart Wester pros
where she's helping people with their
finances in retirement and planning and
teaching them the basics of saving and
things of that nature that have nothing
to do with pushing a debt product she's
got a people skill and she's got a
teacher's heart yeah and those are good
things in the financial world you sort
of move away from banking into something
like the investment side like you're
saying with smart mr. Pro that's a
really good idea